It's recording.
Chop it with your thumb. Y
[Music]
the next one is our face down.
Grab it over here. Right.
We have to call when we get to the
river. Okay.
Try again.
We have uh this one where you grab this
part.
[Music]
And then
you have this show.
He doesn't have the fish. I think
man
you have the uh two clubs anti- spin X
why there are a lot of fake fern that a
lot of fake fern
yeah the the costume
I'm
gear. I like how that's you have to use
that cap which you know
set up on the right.
Can I get that one time on the uh Yeah.
And then uh here you have a
Three club
behind gra
then we have
yeah multi scissor and this one.
Josiah
looks like
it's not rigid.
Close up on the hands. The index pushing
it up.
Opposite direction.
Sometimes I feel like did I ever tell
you about the one time I was having fire
in Kansas like the noise and it was when
I first started swimming double staff so
I was like terrible and um the ice cream
track man showed up and I was like
double staff like
ice cream
the whole time you know
I don't know I feel like at
this
Yeah, that was it.